est ce que vous savez qui est cet homme
ok il fait peur membres il est plutôt
cool bismarck gens tournent dans la
salle c'est celui qui a inventé le
concept de la retraite c'est grâce à lui
vous pouvez aujourd'hui vous arrêter de
bosser et profitez de vos vieux jours
en 1889 bismarck demandé à son
conseiller
à quel âge faut-il que je fixe l'âge de
la retraite pour n'avoir jamais à la
payer son conseiller lui aurait alors
répondu 65 ans s'était alors l'espérance
de vie
il n'était pas folle de bismarck 1
aujourd'hui l'espérance de vie c'est
plus 65 ans c'est 85 ans elle s'est
tellement améliorée qu'on a un tiers de
la population qui a plus de 60 ans c'est
à dire qu'une personne sur 3 vous allez
croiser dans la rue est à la retraite
non mais sérieusement vous êtes jamais
demandé vous qui sont tous ces petits
vieux dans la rue l'un qui vont faire
leurs courses à 19h civile pour elle
quand vous sortez du bureau ou qui vous
pique votre place dans le bus ou encore
qu' on va payer tout et les retraites
là tu as un petit peu loin je pense en
vrai c'est seniors c'est des gens qui
sont encore en pleine forme physique
encore la semaine dernière j'ai pris 6 0
au tennis par mon père de 66 ans ça
c'est pas trop dur
c'est des gens qui ont acquis une
expérience inégalable en travaillant
souvent plus de 40 ans dans le même
métier
et puis vous en conviendrez c'est quand
même des gens qui ont du temps
l'explosion de l'émission des chiffres
et des lettres en est une conséquence
être aujourd'hui à la retraite en france
sinon qu avant une longue expérience que
ce soit personnel ou professionnel
c'est être en bonne santé et c'est
surtout en effet avoir du temps pour
profiter et faire toutes les choses
qu'on a toujours rêvé de faire et
pourtant la retraite en france
si aujourd'hui comme un paradoxe on
connaît tous ce voisin ses parents ou
ses grands-parents qui une fois arrivés
à la retraite a ressenti un manque de
sens le sentiment d'être mis à l'écart
de la société
bref la retraite c'est pas non plus la
joie est en droit de se demander
pourquoi est-elle tant appréhendée tout
au long de notre vie on n'a eu de cesse
d'apprendre à l'âge enfant on va
apprendre à marcher à baragouiner
quelques syllabes plus tard à lire et à
écrire
et puis on va se former pendant nos
études ensuite on va démarrer une
carrière professionnelle pendant
laquelle on va à quelle aune longue
expérience et quand on va arriver à la
retraite tous atteints est mis à l'écart
on passe d'une vie active à une société
dite inactive et en emmène avec nous
toute cette longue expérience
alors qu'aujourd'hui on met en place des
systèmes circulaire qui permettent
d'économiser l'énergie ou encore de
limiter le gaspillage alimentaire
il semblerait qu on soit incapable de
préserver ses savoir faire et de
capitaliser sur cette école de la vie tu
parle d'école par télé mais je chante
profite on s'est rencontré en école
d'ingénieur puis elle était facile à
lille
ont suivi un cursus en bâtiment et
travaux publics comme beaucoup dans la
salle on voulait voir ce qui se passe à
l'étranger
alors on a effectué nos expériences
professionnelles au congo au mexique ou
encore aux philippines
c'est dans ces trois pays qu'on a été
émerveillé par le respect et par
l'importance qu'ils étaient accordées
aux anciens là bas les seniors sont
considérés comme des singes vivent avec
les familles et les échanges
intergénérationnels sont omniprésents
c'est vraiment au congo où je
travaillais sur l'urbanisation d'une
ville la ville de kinkela un petit
village à l'ouest de brazzaville et le
week-end j'étais seul sur la base vie
alors je m'ennuie un petit peu j'allais
me balader pour faire des rencontres
un jour j'ai fait la rencontre justement
de jean aimé le président du club des
sapeurs de king cas là bon là je vous
l'avouer je suis d'accord avec vous il
est pas trop ça paie il est plutôt
benjamin mais reconnaissez quand même sa
classe normalement la sape c'est plutôt
sain je sais pas si tout le monde
connaît ici là sauf la sape
c'est la société des ambianceurs et des
personnes élégantes
ça peut vous paraître absurde un tous
mais c'est une institution à brazzaville
elle réunit tous les dandys congolais
depuis 1960 est l'art de se saper ça se
transmet de génération en génération
ce petit vieux c'était le conseil de
tout le village est en plus de
transmettre son art il transmettait son
savoir vivre et son savoir-être aux
générations en prenant un peu de recul
sur ces dates sur cette anecdote ce que
j'ai envie de raconter là c'est que on a
découvert dans ces pays un modèle
circulaire d'intégration des seniors
dans la société
un modèle où il était vraiment partie
prenante et ce qui est faux à thibault
c'est qu'on a fait ce même constat au
même moment alors qu'on était chacun à
un bout du monde différent l'importance
du rôle des seniors dans l' équilibre de
la société à notre retour en france on
s'est dit qu'il fallait faire quelque
chose
on a donc cherché à comment adapter ce
modèle circulaire notre société et comme
barthélémy et son super sapeurs moi
j'avais un petit vieux qui était encore
mieux au mexique
c'était miguel michael c'était le
réparateur de vélos du quartier il
savait refaire le rayonnage d'une roue
les yeux fermés si je passais autant
avec lui c'est parce que j'aime et
apprendre de sa longue expérience
ces deux expériences justement nous ont
prouvé une chose c'est que si on veut
créer des liens intergénérationnels
râble le mieux c'est encore d'avoir
quelque chose de concret à échanger
entre les deux générations 1 au retour
en france on a commencé à chercher de
tête des pit nous avons commencé à
creuser des groupes facebook au départ
de couture de multiman de tricot crochet
de moi perso j'étais plutôt sur la
mécanique la tricoche de l'ess et à ce
moment là on a troqué nos potes contre
un groupe de super soixantenaire on a
rencontré de plus en plus de jeunes
retraités et de seniors experts dans
différents savoir faire et on les a mis
en relation avec des personnes jeunes ou
moins jeunes qui voulaient apprendre
leur longue expérience au départ on a
commencé chez nous et avec le bouche à
oreille on a commencé à voir plus grand
c'est vrai quand on y réfléchit deux
minutes quoi de mieux que d'apprendre
avec une personne qui a pratiqué par
passion ou par métier une activité
pendant plus de 40 ans
quoi de mieux que d'apprendre à
développer une pellicule par exemple
avec un ancien photoreporter de l'
agence france-presse
ou encore à coudre avec une ancienne
directrice d'un atelier de haute couture
avec ses seniors on a retrouvé en fait
cette convivialité ce partage cette
pêche qui avait et on s'est dit que
c'était peut-être possible de le ramener
en france
à l'origine on n'est pas du tout ce
monde là où on construisait des routes
dans la bamba mexicaine et puis on a
tout lâché pour construire la première
communauté qui permet justement aux
jeunes d'aller chercher l'expérience des
seniors et leur savoir on a envie aussi
de permettre aux retraités en france 2
qui fait leur retraite
désir qui sont là de s'épanouir dans
leur nouvelle vie en rencontrant des
personnes autour leur passion et de se
sentir valorisé en transmettant leur
savoir faire
cette solution leur donner un petit nom
on l'appelait les talents d'alphonse
c'est la première plateforme qui va
connecter des jeunes retraités avec des
personnes désireuses d'apprendre leur
savoir alors se demander comment ça
marche
concrètement c'est hyper simple vous
rendez vous voulez apprendre la musique
la photographie
vous vous rendez sur les talents
d'alphonse points comme vous nous
confiez votre demande et on se charge de
vous mettre en relation avec un alphonse
ultra expérimenté et qui habitent près
de chez vous pour recréer du lien au
niveau local depuis début janvier avec
barthélémy et le lancement notre
plateforme on prend un plaisir fou
justement recevoir toutes ses dates des
anecdotes des duos qu'on a construit
entre seniors non les appelle les
alphonse et les alphonse il
et les jeunes qui veulent apprendre les
curieux prenons l'exemple de nicole qui
a été invité à l'île maurice
chez une personne à qui elle enseigne la
couture ou encore doria tu reçois encore
aujourd'hui trois mois après avoir donné
les derniers cours à clémence des photos
de son bébé
les temps de l'enfance au delà de cette
plate forme de transmission de savoir
faire permet donc de recréer du lien
intergénérationnel durable est
aujourd'hui où un tiers de la population
est à la retraite il est urgent de
repenser un modèle de société où l'on
considère plus les seniors comme un
poids mais comme une ressource
indispensable au bon équilibre de notre
société
l'écrivain malien amadou hampaté bâ le
dit bien la qualité d'une société se
reconnaît à la façon dont elle traite
ses vieux imaginer une société où on
puisse tous avoir un million de papy et
mamie pas deux pas trois pas 4 1
millions une société en fait qui forment
une grande famille merci